What is the largest star in the universe
and why is it that large?
And what are stars anyway?
Things That Would Like To Be Stars
We begin our journey with Earth.
Not to learn anything,
just to get a vague sense of scale.
The smallest things that have
some star-like properties
are large gas giants, or sub-brown dwarfs.
Like Jupiter, the most massive
planet in the solar system.
Eleven times larger and 317
times more massive than Earth,
and more or less, made of
the same stuff as our Sun.
Just much, much less of it.
The transition towards stars
begins with brown dwarfs,
failed stars, that are a huge
disappointment to their moms.
They have between 13 and 90
times the mass of Jupiter.
So even if we took 90 Jupiters and
threw them at each other,
although fun to watch,
it wouldn't be enough to create a star.
Interestingly, adding lots of mass
to a brown dwarf
doesn't make it much bigger,
just its insides denser.
This increases the pressure
in the core enough
to make certain nuclear fusion
reactions happen slowly,
and the object glow a little.
So brown dwarfs are a sort of glowy
gas giant,
that don't fit into any category very
well.
But we want to talk about stars,
not failed wannabe stars, so let's
move on.
Main Sequence Stars
Once large gas balls pass a certain
mass threshold,
their cores become hot and dense
enough to ignite.
Hydrogen is fused to helium in their
cores,
releasing tremendous amounts of energy.
Stars that do that are called
main sequence stars.
The more massive a main sequence star is,
the hotter and brighter it burns,
and the shorter its life is.
Once the hydrogen-burning phase is over,
stars grow up to hundreds of
thousands of times their original size.
But these giant phases only last for a
fraction of their lifespan.
So we'll be comparing stars at
drastically
different stages in their lives.
This doesn't make them less impressive,
but maybe it's good to keep in mind
that we'll be
comparing babies to adults.
Now back to the beginning,
the smallest real stars are red dwarfs.
About 100 times the mass of Jupiter;
barely massive enough to fuse
hydrogen to helium.
Because they are not very massive
they are small, not very hot, and shine
pretty dimly.
They are the only stars in the main
sequence that
don't grow once they die
but sort of fizzle out.
Red dwarfs are by far the most
abundant type in the universe,
because they burn their fuel so slowly,
it lasts them up to ten trillion years -
a thousand times the current age of
the universe.
For example, one of the closest stars
to Earth is a red dwarf star,
Barnard's Star,
but it shines too dimly to be seen
without a telescope.
We made a whole video on red dwarfs
if you want to learn more.
The next stage are stars like our Sun.
To say the Sun dominates the solar
system is not doing it justice
since it makes up 99.86% of all its mass.
It burns far hotter and brighter than
red dwarfs,
which reduces its lifetime to about 10
billion years.
The Sun is 7 times more massive than
Barnard's Star,
but that makes it nearly 300 times
brighter with
twice its surface temperature.
Let's go bigger!
Small changes in mass produce enormous
changes in a main sequence star's
brightness.
The brightest star in the night sky,
Sirius, is 2 solar masses
with a radius 1.7 times that of the Sun,
but its surface is nearly 10,000°C,
making it shine 25 times brighter.
Burning THAT hot reduces its total
lifespan by 4 times to 2.5 billion years.
Stars close to 10 times the mass of
our sun
have surface temperatures near 25,000°C.
Beta Centauri contains two of these
massive stars,
each shining with about 20,000 times
the power of the Sun.
That's a lot of power coming from
something only 13 times larger,
but they'll only burn for about 20
million years.
Entire generations of the blue stars
die in the time
it takes for the Sun to orbit the galaxy
once.
So is this the formula?
The more massive, the larger the star.
The most massive star that we know
is R136a1.
It has 315 solar masses
and is nearly 9 million times brighter
than the Sun.
And yet, despite its tremendous mass
and power,
it's barely 30 times the size of the Sun!
The star is so extreme and barely held
together by gravity
that is loses 321 thousand billion tons
of material through its stellar wind
every single second.
Stars of this sort are extremely rare
because they
break the rules of star formation a
tiny bit.
When supermassive stars are born
they burn extremely hot and bright
and this blows away any extra gas
that could make them more massive.
So the mass limit for such a star is
around 150 times the Sun.
Stars like R136a1 are probably formed
through
the merger of several high mass stars
in dense star-forming regions
and burn their core hydrogen in only
a few million years.
So this means they are rare and short
lived.
From here the trick to going bigger
isn't adding more mass.
To make the biggest stars we have
to kill them.
Red Giants
When main sequence stars begin to
exhaust the hydrogen in their core
it contracts making it hotter and denser.
This leads to hotter and faster fusion
which pushes back against gravity
and makes the outer layers swell in a
giant phase.
And these stars become truly giant indeed.
For example, Gacrux.
Only 30% more massive than the Sun,
it has swollen to about 84 times its
radius.
Still, when the Sun enters the last
stage of its life,
it will swell and become even bigger;
200 times its current radius!
In this final phase of its life
it will swallow the inner planets.
And if you think THAT'S impressive
let's finally introduce the largest stars
in the universe:
Hypergiants
Hypergiants are the giant phase of the
most massive stars in the universe.
They have an enormous surface area
that can radiate an insane amount of
light.
Being so large they're basically
blowing themselves apart
as gravity at the surface is too weak to
hold on to the hot mass
which is lifted away in powerful stellar
winds.
Pistol Star is 25 solar masses
but 300 times the radius of the sun;
a blue hypergiant aptly named for its
energetic blue starlight.
It's hard to say exactly how long Pistol
Star will live
but probably just a few million years.
Even larger than the blue hypergiants
are the yellow hypergiants.
The most well studied is Rho Cassiopeiae;
a star so bright it can be seen with the
naked eye although
it's thousands of lightyears from Earth.
At 40 solar masses,
this star is around 500 times the
radius of the Sun,
and 500,000 times brighter.
If the Earth were as close to Rho
Cassiopeiae as it is to the Sun
it'd be inside it and you would be very
dead.
Yellow hypergiants are very rare though.
Only 15 are known.
This means they're likely just a
short-lived intermediate state
as a star grows or shrinks between
other phases of hypergiantness.
With red hypergiants we reach the
largest stars known to us.
Probably the largest stars even possible!
So who's the winner of this insane
contest?
Well the truth is we don't know.
Red hypergiants are extremely bright
and far away
which means the even tiny
uncertainties in our measurements
can give us a huge margin of error for
their size.
Worse still are solar system sized
behemoths
that are blowing themselves apart
which makes them harder to measure.
As we do more science and our
instruments improve
whatever the largest star is will change.
The star that is currently thought to
be among the largest we've found
is Stephenson 2-18.
It was probably as a main sequence
star a few tens
of times the mass of the sun
and has likely lost about half its mass
by now.
While typical red hypergiants are 1500
times the size of the Sun,
the largest rough estimate places
Stephenson 2-18 at 2150 solar radii,
and shining with almost half a million
times the power of the Sun!
By comparison the Sun seems like a
grain of dust.
Our brains don't really have a way of
grasping this kind of scale.
Even at lightspeed it would take you
8.7 hours to travel around it once.
The fastest plane on Earth would take
around 500 years!
Dropped on the Sun it would fill
Saturn's orbit!
As it evolves it would probably shed
even more mass
and shrink down into another hotter
hypergiant phase,
accumulate heavy elements in its core,
before finally exploding in a core
collapse supernova,
giving its gas back to the galaxy.
This gas will then go on to form
another generation
of stars of all sizes.
Starting the cycle of birth and death
again
to light up our universe.
Let's make this journey again
but this time without the talking.
The universe is BIG.
There are many large things in it.
If you want to play a bit more with size
stuff
we have good news!
We've crated our first app, Universe In
A Nutshell,
together with Tim Urban, the brain
behind Wait But Why.
You can seamlessly travel from the
smallest things in existence,
past the coronavirus,
human cells and dinosaurs,
all the way to the largest stars
and galaxies,
and marvel at the whole observable
universe!
You can learn more about each object,
or simply enjoy the sheer scale of it all.
The app is inspired by the Scale Of
The Universe website
by the Huang twins,
that we spent a lot of time with when
it came out years ago,
and felt that it was finally time to
create a
Wait But Why and Kurzgesagt version.
You can get it in your app store,
there are no in-app purchases, and no ads.
All future updates are included.
And since this is our first app
we'd love to hear your feedback
so we can improve it over time.
If this sounds good to you
download the Universe In A Nutshell
app now
and leave us a 5-star review if you
want to support it.
Kurzgesagt and all the projects we do
are mostly funded by viewers
like you!
So if you like the app we'll make more
digital things in future.
Thank you for watching!